the trainer api
the transformers library provides a
trainer api that allows you to easily
fine-tune transformers models
on your data set the trainer class
secure data sets
your model as well as the training ipad
parameters
and can perform the training on any kind
of setup cpu gpu
multiple gpus tpus can also compute the
predictions on any data set and if your
provided metrics
evaluate your model on any data set
you can also undo final data processing
such as dynamic padding
as long as you provide the tokenizer or
a given data collater
we'll try this api in the mrpc dataset
since it's relatively small
and easy to pre-process as we saw in the
datasets overview video
very though we can preprocess it we do
not apply padding during the
preprocessing
as we will use dynamic padding with our
data collector with padding
note that we don't do the final steps of
renaming removing columns
or set the format to torch tensors the
trainer will do all of this
automatically for us
by analyzing the model's signature
the last step before creating the
trainer are to define our model
and some training upper parameters we
see how to do the first
in the model api video for the second
we use the training argument class it
only takes a path to a folder where
results and checkpoint will be saved
but you can also customize all the other
parameters that your trainer will use
learning rate number of training inbox
etc
it's been very easy to create a trainer
on launcher training
this should display a progress bar and
after a few minutes
if you're running on a gpu you should
have the training finished
the result will be rather anticlimactic
however as you will only get a training
loss
which doesn't really tell you anything
about how well your model is performing
this is because we didn't specify any
metric for the evaluation
to get those metrics we'll first cover
the predictions on the wall evaluation
set
using the predict method it returns a
name to paul with three fields
prediction which contains the model
predictions label ids
which contains the labels if you data
set at them and metrics which is empty
here
we're trying to do that the predictions
are the luggage of the models for all
the sentences in the data set
so an empire ray of shape 408 by two
to match them with our labels we need to
take the maximum logic for each
prediction
to know which of the two classes was
predicted we do
this with the rmax function then we can
use the matrix from the datasets library
it can be loaded as easily as a dataset
with the loadmetric function
and it returns the evaluation metric
used for the dataset
we can see our model did learn something
as it is 85.7 percent accurate
to monitor the evaluation matrix during
training we need to define a compute
metric function
that does the same step as before it
takes a name to pull with predictions
and labels
and must return a dictionary of the
metrics we want to keep track of
by passing the epoch evaluation strategy
to our training arguments
we tell the trainer to evaluate at the
end of every epoch
launching a training inside a notebook
will then display a progress bar
and complete the table you see here as
you pass every epoch